ich bin vielleicht zunächst mit der
guten nachricht weil ich gute
nachrichten in tagen wie diesen ohnehin
spärlich sind die gute nachricht ist der
lok dann hat in österreich wirkung
gezeigt wir haben es geschafft gemeinsam
von einer sieben tage incidence von rund
150 auf eine sieben tage in sequenz von
rund 100 zu sinken
wir sind damit was die ansteckungszahlen
betrifft im besten drittel innerhalb der
europäischen union
die schlechte nachricht und auch die
muss genauso öffentlich gemacht werden
die mutationen breiten sich aus vor
allem die britische aber auch die
südafrikanische variante und diese
mutationen wirken sich auch auf sie
fressen sozusagen ein stück weit den
erfolg unseres lock down south das
bedeutet zusammengefasst während die
klassische virusvariante im sinken ist
steigen die mutationen an
und das führt im ergebnis dazu dass wir
mittlerweile in einer seitwärtsbewegung
angelangt sind
vom ideal szenario einer sieben tage
incidents von rund 50 also rund 700
ansteckungen pro tag sind wir mit
unseren 1000 bis 1500 ansteckungen pro
tag weit entfernt es ist daher heute
maximal möglich nur sehr behutsame
öffnung schritte zu setzen und auch das
nur wenn diese mit intensiven
sicherheits und begleitmaßnahmen
verbunden sind
etymologisch ist die sache ganz klar
der sicherste weg wäre es im lokal zu
verharren aber ja wir wissen es gibt
auch das bedürfnis der kinder wieder in
die schule zu gehen
es gibt die notwendigkeit alles zu tun
um die arbeitslosigkeit so gering wie
möglich zu halten und es gibt natürlich
auch soziale und psychische aspekte die
auch mit einfließen müssen wir haben uns
daher einstimmig alle
bundesländer und die bundesregierung
darauf verständigt einige vorsichtige
öffnung schritte vorzunehmen aber
gleichzeitig auch andere sicherungs
schritte und verschärfungen einzuführen
und ich darf in gewohnter art und weise
kurz diesen plan schildern
ich beginne bei einem bereich der uns
ein ganz besonders am herzen liegt und
war immer klar war wenn es irgendwie
möglich ist wollen wir hier öffnung
schritte setzen und das sind die schulen
haben uns darauf verständigt dass die
schulen nach den semesterferien
das ist in wien und in niederösterreich
ab dem 8 februar und in den anderen
bundesländern eine woche später dass die
schulen nach den semesterferien wieder
zum präsenzunterricht zurückkehren
sollen das bedeutet vollständiger
präsenzunterricht für die volksschulen
und ein schichtbetrieb für die
unterstufe und die oberstufe ganz
wesentlich erscheint uns dass wir das
nicht einfach ungesichert machen sondern
mit einem ausgeklügelten test konzept
das bedeutet alle schülerinnen und
schüler werden bei schulbeginn in der
schule getestet und dieser test hat eine
gültigkeit für 48 stunden
sprich wenn in einem schichtbetrieb der
unterricht stattfindet dann kommt der
eine teil der klasse am montag hinein
wird am montag in der früh getestet und
hat am montag und am dienstag
präsenzunterricht und der zweite teil
der klasse kommt am mittwoch hinein und
hat am mittwoch und am donnerstag
unterricht die einen werden am montag
getestet die anderen werden am mittwoch
getestet und sind dann jeweils zwei tage
in der schule in der volksschule erfolgt
zweimal die woche eine testung da es
hier einen vollständigen
präsenzunterricht ohne schicht betrieb
geben soll
genaue details wird der bildungsminister
morgen in einer pressekonferenz
präsentieren
die schule ist eine herausforderung weil
das über eine million schülerinnen und
schüler betrifft die dadurch wieder in
den präsenzunterricht zurückkehren die
im öffentlichen verkehr und im
öffentlichen raum natürlich dadurch auch
wieder stärker präsent sind und daher
ist diese testung so ganz besonders
wichtig um hier alles zu tun um schule
so sicher als möglich auch stattfinden
lassen zu können
ab dem 8 februar sollen darüber hinaus
handle museen tierparks wieder öffnen
können was den handel betrifft aber auch
die anderen bereiche selbstverständlich
auch mit klaren schutzmaßnahmen das
tragen von fsp zwei masken wird
verpflichtend sein und darüber hinaus
wird die quadratmeter begrenzung die wir
bisher bei 10 quadratmeter hatten auf 20
quadratmeter ausgedehnt das betrifft
jetzt den einzelnen bürger nicht aber
die unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
sehr wohl
das ist eine einschneidende maßnahme
aber eine maßnahme die uns notwendig
erscheint um hier eine bestmögliche
entzerrung auch sicherzustellen
wir haben uns darüber hinaus entschieden
die körpernahen dienstleister auch ab
dem 8 februar zu öffnen für alle die
sich unter diesen sperrigen begriff
nichts vorstellen können das betrifft
friseure und andere branchen und hier
werden wir auf das konzept der eintritt
tests setzen
das bedeutet wie gesetzlich vor einigen
wochen gemeinsam geregelt dass es
möglich ist einen friseurtermin oder
anderes wahrzunehmen
dass man allerdings 48 stunden vorher
einen test machen muss oder einen test
vorher machen muss der maximal 48
stunden gültigkeit hat das kann jeder in
privaten bereich machen wie zum beispiel
in der apotheke oder beim arzt vor allem
aber ist doch ein kostenloses angebot
seitens der länder hier möglich ihnen
den bewährten test straßen in wien
glaube ich
zum beispiel in der stadthalle und an
anderen orten aber auch in den
bundesländern sehr sehr dezentral
bereits organisiert wir wissen dass das
natürlich eine gewisse herausforderung
ist und dass das eine starke hürde
darstellt aber die alternative wäre
gewesen dieser körpernahen dienstleister
gar nicht zu öffnen und daher ist unsere
klare entscheidung gewesen lieber mit
test zu öffnen als gar nicht aufzuspüren
für den privaten bereich wird es ab dem
8 februar wieder erlaubt sein dass sich
zwei haushalte treffen dürfen
das heißt sprich ein haushalt zum
beispiel ein ehepaar hat die möglichkeit
einen zweiten haushalt ein anderes
ehepaar maximal vier erwachsene personen
aus zwei haushalten zu treffen
ich sag dazu je weniger private treffen
stattfinden desto besser je weniger
soziale kontakte es gibt desto besser
und wenn sie soziale kontakte haben
versuchen sie diese auf einen sehr sehr
eingeschränkten kreis zu reduzieren
immer maximal einen zweiten haushalt die
nächtlichen ausgangssperren bleiben
bestehen nämlich von 20 bis 6 uhr
darüber hinaus ist es notwendig aus
unserer sicht in zwei bereichen
verschärfungen vorzunehmen zum einen
haben wir immer wieder gesehen dass es
vermehrt verstöße gegen die regelungen
gibt
das wäre gar nicht so problematisch wenn
sich die personen nur selbst gefährden
würden aber sie gefährden auch andere
ich sage das in aller deutlichkeit werk
eine maske trägt wer bei einer
demonstration passanten an spuckt oder
anderes der gefährdet andere menschen
und das ist kein kavaliersdelikt wir uns
daher auch darauf verständigt dass wir
die strafen die es gibt noch einmal
deutlich anheben wollen um auch zu
zeigen dass es für die gefährdung an
menschen in unserer gesellschaft keine
toleranz gibt der innenminister wird
hier alle details morgen präsentieren
und der letzte punkt wir müssen auch bei
den grenzen nach schärfen wir wissen
dass die mutationen eine extreme
herausforderung für uns sind weil sie zu
einer schnelleren ausbreitung des virus
führen weil sie uns für immer neue
herausforderungen stellen und daher
werden wir das grants regime noch einmal
deutlich verschärfen müssen um zu
verhindern dass wir uns mutationen aus
anderen teilen der welt einschleppen
das britische virus hat sich
mittlerweile in österreich verbreitet
auch die südafrikanische variante ist
mittlerweile in österreich angekommen
aber weitere varianten wie zum beispiel
die variante aus brasilien und andere
können noch abgewehrt werden oder es
kann zumindest der zeitpunkt an dem
diese varianten nach österreich
eingeschleppt werden nach hinten
verschoben werden
am 15 februar also in zwei wochen werden
wir im kreis wie heute zusammenkommen
und die situation evaluieren wie
versprochen werden wir am 15
februar über mögliche weitere öffnungen
sprechen wie zum beispiel den tourismus
die gastronomie den sportbereich den
kulturbereich alle bereiche wo wir schon
vor zwei wochen entschieden haben dass
es im februar jedenfalls keine öffnung
geben wird ob es hier eine perspektive
ab anfang märz gibt das werden wir am 15
februar entscheiden
ich sage aber auch dazu sollte sich die
situation bis zum 15 februar
verschlechtern und auch das ist ein
realistisches szenario
dann werden wir selbstverständlich auch
darüber beraten wie wir darauf reagieren
müssen
zum abschluss sehr geehrte damen und
herren ist es mir noch ein persönliches
anliegen eine nicht unwesentliche
wahrheit auszusprechen
die ansteckungszahlen die wir in
österreich haben die hängen nur bedingt
von den entscheidungen ab die wir heute
getroffen
ob die eine oder andere branche offen
oder zu ist all das hat auswirkungen
keine frage aber viel wichtiger ist es
wie verhält sich jeder einzelne privat
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel wenn sie mit
fb2 maske im handel unterwegs sind und
jeder der einkaufen geht 20 quadratmeter
platz zur verfügung hat dann ist die
chance sich dort anzustecken wirklich
äußerst gering
aber wenn man sich privat mit freunden
oder der familie trifft und einer hat
das virus ohne es zu wissen dann ist die
chance dass er alle anderen ansteckt
irrsinnig groß
ich erlebe immer wieder bei menschen bei
freunden bei bekannten dass sie so bald
auf der straße jemand nur leicht zu
husten beginnt sofort das weite suchen
und gleicht die straßenseite wechseln
und das auch wenn beide eine maske
tragen
aber sobald man privat zusammen kommt da
fallen nicht nur die masken sondern es
gibt auch überhaupt keine sorge mehr
sich anzustecken
wir glauben oft dass die menschen die
uns vertraut sind ungefährlich sind oder
nicht gefährdet sind uns das virus zu
übertragen
genau das gegenteil ist der fall und
daher ist unsere große bitte gerade im
privaten bereich vorsichtig zu sein
gerade soziale kontakte zu vermeiden
damit wir auch eine chance haben dass
diese vorsichtigen öffnung schritte
bestand haben können
drei kurze punkte zum abschluss
bitte verstehen sie diese punktuellen
lockerungen nicht als entwarnung
zweitens wenn die zahlen steigen wenn
die zahlen exponentiell steigen und das
ist ein realistisches szenario
dann werden wir sofort wieder
verschärfen müssen
und drittens wie lange das dauert bis
die zahlen exponentiell ansteigen
das hängt von uns allen ab und davon wie
wir uns verhalten und ganz besonders
davon wie wir uns privat verhalten
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren